so good to see you dina and jenny omg
now i don't even know how you are here
right now mama
how are you doing because you just had
your second baby yes
i'm good my mom is actually with both
kids in the other room so one of them
cj might pop in here and there we'll see
but i'm doing good this is my first week
on my own my husband just went back to
work so but we're in a routine and
we're getting in the groove over here
you're someone right now so you're now a
party of four
is your heart just as full is it right
now oh my god it's
the best it's the best um
i love it i love it so good dana well
y'all we are gearing up the family
vacation is continuing
and we are so pumped for it the trailer
getting us ready
said get ready for a vacation you won't
sure get what is so unforgettable about
this family vacation we're in store for
for me personally it was the fact that i
was able to bring my family for the
whole vacation
and all of us actually did you know to
have my kids there for my daughter to be
able to be virtual with school
it really just felt so complete and
you're able to see that dynamic of
everyone's
family you know being in a coveted
bubble
unbelievable and speaking of being with
your family i just saw a post that you
recently
put out there about grayson and that
he's doing so well and he's making
remarkable progress
he's with this therapist right now and
his therapy is ending he's
killing it he's an aba um
and he probably will run to the camera
any minute so just be prepared
ready for it grayson come make your bts
buddy that's great to hear do you have
any advice to parents that are going
through this
a similar journey as yours my biggest
thing with
anybody is just don't ignore any of the
signs
if you see anything it's best to ask
your pediatrician
there's no harm in getting you know
speech or
any type of ot even before a diagnosis
you know it's really can help the
younger they are
the more of a chance that they have of
you know
gaining the momentum so they can be with
their peers and that's my goal for
grayson is that he'll be able to walk
in kindergarten or first grade with his
peers
and you would never know the difference
that is awesome jenny and you are giving
him the tools and the resources to do
just that
super mom yeah keep on keeping on mama
that is for sure
we're going for mom right now
[Laughter]
she is indeed now speaking mama's mama
snooki is coming back
ladies and gentlemen parties here so
what was it like having her
back in action on a vacay and just how
crazy did the things get with snooki in
the minutes
i mean she's snooky so you know
she had a really good time well we'll
put it that way
how she just literally falls on her face
off the stage
so she didn't miss a beat that's for
sure it was like she never left
she came back and it was like we were
whole again
and we were just so happy to have our
meatball back oh they're a little
meatball
your little meatball is so tiny but that
girl is feisty
she is something else intel why did she
decide to return at this time i know she
needed to take a break
actually she never actually even
answered us as to why she
came back she just wanted to come back
and she wanted to make the grand
entrance and she wanted to do it big and
surprise us all and
i was always optimistic but i don't know
i started crying because i actually
probably deep down inside i didn't think
she was coming back yeah i didn't
i thought she was done for good i
thought you know she was ready to move
on and just be with her family
and i think when she saw that you know
because we all
keep in touch every day so once she knew
that like we had moved past things with
angelina and i feel like things were
settling down
i think that's when she was like okay i
think maybe
mentally this will be an okay time to
come back because
there it wasn't so much confrontation
and i think once everything's settled
down i think that's that's
when she was like okay i think this
would be a good time to come back and
you just didn't want to see the drama
and or be a part of the drama
totally get it on that front because it
was pretty short it was a lot it was
definitely a lot
it was a lot and it spanned a whole
chunk of time with you guys but yeah
yeah we clean it all we've seen the good
the bad the ugly
how is it that you guys are able to
continue to stick by one another during
these
joyous and even trying times i think it
really comes down to having like a real
relationship with each other
treating each other like a real family
so when you have
that family aspect you know just like
your blood family
you go through your ups and downs and
you know
we talk to each other every day like
it's
kind of freakish how much how very close
we are we have a group chat
and we have a sister's chat with just
the girls and we talk
every single day and i think that's what
helps us
when it comes to the disagreements and
the fights
and the bitterness that can happen on
reality tv
because we'll always choose each other
over
cameras jenny would you say that you get
engaged this season
so how is wedding planning going are you
in the thick of it right now
what's going on with that process
actually the opposite
um we haven't started anything we're
waiting
to see how coveted and weddings just how
like they start to break down whether if
you're gonna have to wear masks no mask
uh new jersey tomorrow actually they're
lifting the mask
mandates so baby steps and
i have a lot of friends that are like
wedding photographers
and videographers so i'm just kind of
like keeping up to date with them to see
like
you know what's the capacities how is
everybody doing
is there any outbreaks and then when i
feel like it's comfortable we'll start
[Music]
planning